foreign
[Music]
shows off his dance moves on Sister
Wives
[Music]
I'm just a guy who just doesn't hold
back the Brown family patriarch takes a
solo road trip to attend his pal Brian's
wedding in Oklahoma and because he's
officiating he's breaking his strict
coveted rules I decided to stop checking
covid numbers it seems like it's safe to
sort of poke my head out I am feeling
like it's time to sort of emerge from
all this quarantining the sequester that
we've had with coven but Cody doesn't
quite feel prepared to officiate mostly
because his marriage with Christine just
ended my thoughts so far about marriage
ironically have been mixed
and it's crazy that I'm here performing
this wedding he was questioning whether
he was the best guy to talk at a wedding
when he was struggling so much in his
relationship he would bring that up
often with me in conversation because he
feels like it's a little bit of a
failure that he that this this marriage
is falling apart the timing for me to
leave was just it opened up and
everything became just things fell into
place so well but despite being nervous
Cody follows through and MC's the ideas
each others being a standard
he does a pretty good job and he doesn't
says things that other people only wish
they could and while the wedding looked
great fans are zoning in on one thing
when he busted a move at the reception
[Music]
that's the crowd circling around Cody
then at one point he dances with a
fellow guest
[Music]
but while Cody's having a good time
Janelle and Christine get a little
heated taking offense to his decision to
hit up a wedding after he refused to see
them and their kids amid the pandemic I
see Christine and I see Mary and I see
Janelle and I see Robin all of them
based upon uh essentially their behavior
regarding the outside world you know
because of covet 19. yeah the travel
choice is interesting to me and I
realize it's important but Cody and
Robin still observed the very strict
rules about covid and yet here's Cody
traveling are you gonna mask up while
you're officiating are they going to
have to follow Cody's no that's
ridiculous they're not going to have to
follow Cody's rules but the one thing
that really infuriates Christine how
Cody made an exception to go to a
wedding but chose to skip their daughter
Isabelle's surgery
Isabelle's heartbroken she goes how can
he justify officiating Brian's wedding
when he wouldn't even come to my surgery
and now I'm mad what the hell you think
you gotta go officiate your friend's
wedding and not take care of your own
family you know it's hard it's difficult
but I work hopefully going to be fine
you know I think I was a lot more
optimistic that we would be like besties
so I'm not quite sure about that but
we'll see but then Cody explains there
was a bigger reason behind it Isabel's
surgery was at a time and a situation
where it would have required that I am
six or eight weeks away from home no man
could be away from work and from home
and from family that long
I was gone for four days for Brian's
wedding the lack of love between us was
for a reason
so glad I'm not because I cannot respect
this person anymore fast forward to
present day and Christine's happy live
in that single life that's more like a
personal strength that I feel like I
have more than I've ever felt before
because I was able to make steps for my
future and for my present and so I just
feel more confident as well and while
the TLC star is not yet ready for a new
relationship she tells ET the quality
she's looking for in her next partner
kindness
real just kindness a romantic
relationship for sure someone who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that
[Music]